a música que Adele Adele Não a beyon
achou de mim eu quero que vocês me
ajudem a fazer o coral
quero que vocês participem
quero que vocês participam
[Música]
o coral vocês vão fazer simples
vocês vão fazer todos assim
[Música]
só isso que vocês vão fazer Tá mas eu
vou dividir aqui esse anel de baixo e
essa parte de baixo vão fazer o hello
hello
o anel de cima
aqui é assim pagou menos participa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
fazer tudo quanto tudo que eu vou cantar
no Rock in Rio e eu não tenho tempo para
ensaiar para ensaiar com vocês tá
ela que baixo ela um dois três
em cima
[Música]
Vocês são muito brutos
ou você pode ser singelo
simples
[Música]
mas hoje
Agora presta atenção
o maestro quando está fazendo
[Música]
a mão esquerda ele aponta para quem ele
quer que faça determinada ação
com as duas mãos quando ele levanta para
cantar mais alto mais firme
quando ele abaixa as mãos na época tá
mais suave mas suave entendeu
[Música]
vai ficar bonito
eu tava com meu primo eu
jogando bola no quintal
ele falou porque nós não sai andar de
bike é bem mais legal
eu falei não dá certo eu minha mãe
chegando me espancar
ele falou vou deixar de ser burro ela
saiu foi trabalhar
minha bike Então eu peguei
uma corrida com ele apostei eu eu contou
até três mas nos dois comercial pedalar
era postado r$ 1 eu falava isso eu já
ganhei foi aí que o Wilson gritou a tua
mãe que tá sem freio eu acordei no
hospital
minha mãe que se partiu no meio da queda
que eu levei e me retornou os cotovelo e
o joelho
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu acordei no hospital
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como seria essa paródia do Ratinho bota
aí toca aí para mim
[Música]